oh boy there's a lot to talk about here
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by bright
sellers and we'll be reviewing fitness
youtuber and influencer chrissy sila but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
brightsellers so brightsellers is a wine
box experience that pairs you with wine
that you will love and then delivers it
right to your door i find that i always
have a really hard time choosing a wine
at the liquor store because
honestly what can you go by other than
the look of the bottle so bright sealers
is a bit like having a virtual sommelier
in your back pocket and a delivery
service ready to get that wine to you
stat you simply fill out a quiz to
determine your taste preferences and
they share six unique wines that you're
most likely to enjoy from around the
world so they ask you questions like
what are your favorite flavors of juice
and what kinds of chocolate do you like
and then they make recommendations based
on those flavor profiles i'm honestly
not necessarily a wine expert i just
know that i like it well
a lot so i feel like the service has
helped teach me what i like about my
wine but also about wine in general
so if you want to find your own dream
wine pack you can check out my link
below to get 50 off of your first six
bottle box now you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating i will be talking macros and
calories so you can feel free to skip
that portion if that's not supportive to
your journey also don't forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
little bell so that you never miss out
on a episode all right so a little bit
about chrissy before we get too far into
the review chrissy is a uk-based
influencer who posts all sorts of
fitness content to your youtube channel
and instagram page including what i eat
in a days daily vlogs and workout with
me videos and from the looks of it
chrissy's hard work that she's put into
her platforms has certainly paid off she
currently has over 700 000 subscribers
on youtube over 2 million followers on
instagram a fitness app that she created
called tone and sculpt and a line of
supplements in partnership with women's
best as well as her own line of
activewear so yeah i guess you could say
that she's doing okay so today we're
going to take a look at the what i in a
day that's the most recent at the time
of filming this titled what i eat in a
day to stay lean and the supplements
that i use let's take a look
okay so this protein oatmeal looks
awesome we've got carbs and fiber in the
oats and blueberries protein and the
chocolate whey protein powder from her
line
some healthy fats from the peanut butter
and a little agave to sweeten now a lot
of people do ask me if agave is
healthier than regular sugar so i
thought we would break this one down
agave and regular white table sugar are
considered simple carbohydrates and if
we look at the nutritionals a tablespoon
of white sugar provides 12 and a half
grams of carbs and 48 calories while one
tablespoon of agave supplies 16 grams of
carbs and 60 calories
largely because it's a liquid sweetener
and therefore more molecules can fit
into a spoon now common argument in
favor of agave is that it contains
micronutrients that something like white
sugar and other sweeteners do not and
while this is technically true that
agave does have some trace vitamins and
minerals like vitamin c vitamin a and
selenium you would need so
much of the sweetener in order to obtain
any significant amounts so please
don't try to get your vitamin c intake
from sugar now agave has also been
popularized due to its lower glycemic
index in reference to other sweeteners
thanks to the fact that it's 90
fructose but the american diabetes
association suggests that we should be
treating agave the same as we would any
other fructose or glucose based
sweetener so
my advice is to just choose whichever
sweetener that you enjoy the most and
ultimately use it mindfully all right
let's see what's next whenever i
struggle to drink water what i do is i
get a scoop
of bcaas this is my rainbow candy
bcaa's rainbow candy and then i mix it
in
and i drink that and it's just so much
easier to drink because it tastes so
good okay so i get that a lot of us
don't love the taste of boring old h2o
so adding in some kind of flavor might
help you get your fill and let's be real
rainbow candy water does sound good now
this is actually a flavored bcaa
supplement from chrissy's line with
women's best which is a supplement
category not without some controversy
for those who don't know
bcaas or branch chain amino acids are a
group of three essential amino acids
leucine isoleucine and valine that are
intended to increase muscle protein
synthesis and muscle growth and prevent
muscle breakdown and while this is true
for those who have low intake of dietary
protein for those getting around one to
one and a half grams per kilogram of
body weight per day the evidence
suggests that it's likely very much
unnecessary in fact we do have research
to suggest that food or complete sources
of protein may be much more helpful and
honestly she already got her protein in
the form of her prose now don't get me
wrong if adding flavored bcaas helps
chrissy stay hydrated and meet her fluid
requirements i would say that that is a
priority at least it would be for me but
i'm more so just pointing this out to
suggest that as long as you're getting
enough good quality protein in your diet
throughout the day there's generally no
need to be supplementing with additional
bcaa supplements all right folks let's
take a look at lunch
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this looks simple but of course very
nutritious we've got lots of protein in
the air fried salmon some fiber-rich
veggies in the mixed green salad with
some healthy fats from the olive oil and
fish now while this lunch is packed with
protein and healthy fats it's definitely
lower in the carb department i mean if
this was to be a post-workout meal i
would say yeah we would definitely want
to up the carbs
but she did have a solid amount of carbs
at breakfast and i know that there is
more coming at snack so in the context
of her day
it all balances out
not every meal or snack needs to be
perfectly balanced so speaking of snack
let's take a peek so now it's my
favorite part of the day it is
pre-workout time so i've got some peanut
butter and jam here on two slices of
toast i'm gonna have that and then
straight after i'm gonna have
my favorite ever you have no idea i look
forward to having this every day
the pre-workout of dreams so i'm gonna
have it in my woman's best shaker i feel
very seen on the sweet versus savory
toast dilemma this is just like always a
daily struggle for me and
i too have just succumbed to the reality
that i will forever need one of each but
yeah this is a really
great pre-workout meal so we've got a
healthy dose of energizing carbs from
the bread and the jam
plus a little fat and protein to help
satiety to get her through the gym sesh
but not so much that it would risk
causing digestive distress so this is
actually a pretty good option as a
pre-workout snack chrissy also takes a
pre-workout supplement with her snack
which once again is from her own line
now i did a little bit of research into
her supplement line with women's best
and i think it's important to mention
that the products are not third party
tested
i spoke about why this is so important
in my video on supplements here but in
short third-party testing involves an
independent unbiased organization
reviewing a product to see if it meets
certain criteria standards for quality
and safety now although individual
ingredients in these products are
regulated like the creatine in this
particular pre-workout supplement the
actual products as a whole
are not now i'm not saying that
chrissy's supplements are unsafe but i
do always flag that the supplement world
is really like the wild west and unless
you have an unbiased party taking a look
to make sure that everything's kosher
you really just don't know anyways back
to this pre-workout supplement here the
first ingredient in this product is
l-arginine alpha-ketoglutarate which
acts to increase nitric oxide production
and vasodilation
aka the widening of blood vessels which
would allow more oxygen to come to the
body for easier energy output during
exercise this sounds super important in
theory but the research on aakg
supplements like this are admittedly
kind of mixed it's ultimately hard to
tell whether vasodilation during
exercise is due to the supplement or
simply the active exercise itself now
the next common ingredient in these
pre-workouts is creatine
so creatine is an organic amino acid
that helps supply energy to the cells
and makes the muscle cells look bigger
by pulling water into them so we do have
evidence to suggest that it has a lot of
benefits so the cited benefits of
creatine as a supplement includes better
workout intensity greater training
adaptations enhanced post exercise
recovery reduced injury risk and more
and in the world of sports supplements i
would say that creatine is one of the
best supported ones in the literature
there's also beta alanine which is
another amino acid which is meant to
produce carnosine to reduce lactic acid
accumulation in the muscles now research
from one meta-analysis showed increased
performance stamina and recovery in
athletes who are supplementing with
beta-alanine however it's worth noting
that beta-alanine has been known to
cause some like tingling as a really
unpleasant side effect so a lot of folks
including myself
just can't tolerate it at all finally
there's about 100 milligrams of caffeine
per serving in the supplement which is
about the same amount as a cup of coffee
which is not outrageous considering a
lot of other pre-workouts have a lot
more but of course if you're taking this
at the end of the day it's just
something to be aware of so if you're
looking for a pre-workout supplement you
might want to keep tabs on the caffeine
levels as well as pay attention to any
unwanted side effects jitteriness
anxiety nausea flushing and tingling are
not uncommon side effects there have
also been people who have died from
contaminated unregulated pre-workout
supplements so you'll definitely want to
pay really close attention to how you
react to a pre-workout and of course
adjust as needed if you're sensitive to
caffeine look for one without it
if you're experiencing flushing look for
an option without niacin if you're
dealing with tingling face and lips then
an option without beta alanine may be
best but whatever you choose i do
strongly urge you to look for one that
is third party tested through something
like labdor.com nsf sport or informed
choice and always speak to a doctor or
dietitian before starting a supplement
routine all right folks
i am ready for a post-workout snack
[Music]
[Music]
best protein shake ever my gosh i get so
excited
okay so refueling after her heavy
workout with some protein here we've got
a simple protein shake with some kind of
milk and her brand of protein powder now
i know that we often think about needing
protein after a workout but carbs are
actually arguably even more important we
actually want to aim for a three to one
carb to protein ratio after working out
to help to refuel our muscles replenish
our glycogen stores and help to drive
that protein into the muscle faster so
it would be super simple to just throw
in some frozen berries or like a banana
or some oats into the shake just to get
a little bit more of that optimal
post-workout ratio in this snack but
let's take a look at dinner
yum
love me a good rotisserie chicken and
nando's where she ordered this from i
feel like it's like a solid
step up from swiss lay but you don't get
the shallow dipping sauce which to me is
kind of the whole point of ordering
rotisserie chicken i could legit drink
that stuff but comment below if you are
team nando's or swiss chalet i don't
even know if social a is just a canadian
thing but if it is and you're canadian
leave me a comment below and you educate
everyone else on the beauty of the
chalet dipping sauce i mean i know i'm
getting off track here but i'm just
excited about swish lake dipping sauce
anyway
kristy has quite an awesome little
spread here we've got protein in the
chicken carbs in the rice french fries
corn biscuit i've got some fat in the
cheese and some broccoli for veg the
girl is representing our food group
rainbow here
and i'm totally here for it and since
she does have a good amount of carbs in
this meal i think it balances out some
of the higher protein snacks and lunch
earlier on i normally would probably
like to see a little bit more colorful
vegetables in here
but i will say since she had a big salad
for lunch again all balance is out this
is also a restaurant meal so the fact
that there is any vegetable on our plate
feels like a major win to me all right
folks now let's talk about the stats and
again trigger warning i am going to talk
numbers so please feel free to skip
ahead to the time stamp on the screen if
that is triggering for you according to
my calculations chrissy's day came out
to a total of
2373 calories with around 41 of our
calories coming from carbs 19 from fat
and about 40
from protein her macros are a little bit
lower in fat and higher in protein but
again if this works for chrissy then it
works for me it's also very hard for me
to assess someone's overall dietary
patterns from just one day so this may
have just been a lower fat and higher
protein day for her and it's totally
normal for our macronutrient
distributions to fluctuate from day to
day i will also say that our fiber
intake is slightly below both the
canadian and uk recommendations for most
adults but this is just kind of another
aspect of one's diet that is not only
normal to see variations in each day but
also highly individual depending on what
intake makes each person feel their best
so let's talk about what i'm liking here
so first of all it's definitely
refreshing to see a young fitness
influencer consuming enough to likely
meet her energy needs while also not
completely demonizing or cutting out
specific foods or food groups i also
appreciate her relaxed and cheerful
approach to food where she seems
genuinely excited by different flavors
and foods and doesn't seem overly
concerned with counting calories or
tracking everything that enters her body
i also love seeing her flexibility in
ordering in and not fussing over the
inability to control her macros or
calories in her takeaway meal now with
the exception of all the supplements
which i'll speak more to in a minute her
meals feel pretty accessible simple and
uncomplicated you know basically things
that busy folks like you or i could make
on the fly for just one person if needed
and i think a lot of people are looking
for more solo meal ideas these days so i
do think that that's really great now i
don't know this for sure but it would
seem like she may also be in kind of
like a cutting phase right now just
based on the juxtaposition of this video
title with her last one which was all
about what to eat to gain muscle so if
that's true
this may explain why her meals are a
little bit lower carb as i noticed in
the video on gaining muscle that she
actually ate a lot more food so for
example her breakfast in that video
included eggs with her protein oats her
lunch had pita bread and sweet potato
her shake added in banana and peanut
butter and she also had some kind of
chocolate dessert in the day in fact i
specifically really love what she says
about having chocolate every single day
so let's just quickly take a little
look-see but um
yeah i have a bit of this every day and
if anyone's watching this and as a
dietitian or a nutritionist and it's
like oh my god this is terrible for you
it's good for my soul um this is what i
eat in a day so please
don't judge me i am a dietitian and i am
watching this and i am not going to
judge in fact i think it's really nice
to see a fitness influencer eating foods
that also nourish their soul so i got
you girl so i think it's clear to me
that chrissy has some physical or
aesthetic goals which are totally valid
and she's absolutely entitled to that
but from what i can see i feel like
she's able to tweak her diet in a way to
help her meet those goals without making
herself feel overwhelmingly restricted
and letting it interfere with her
ability to live her life and enjoy food
finally let's quickly talk about some
gentle nutrition tips i think i want to
start by saying that there are a lot of
supplements in her day i mean i know
that this is her line so rightfully so
she's trying to promote it but it does
feel a little bit like a 20-minute ad
we've got protein powder twice a day
plus bcaas plus the pre-workout i think
that the powders all got way more air
time than any actual food honestly i
really think that protein powder can be
a really great convenient option for
busy folks and i use it myself for that
reason but i do want people to know that
it's possible to achieve these same
results without having to rely on so
many supplements multiple times a day
she could easily swap in some greek
yogurt tofu or cottage cheese in her
smoothie if she already had protein
powder in her oats
and if she's consistently getting in
protein from you know the chicken fish
and protein powder she can probably
forgo the bcaas i would also focus on
sneaking a few more high fiber veggies
fruit or whole grains in there as her
fiber numbers are a little bit low so
perhaps adding some extra veggies to her
dinner adding a little fruit to her
smoothie throwing in some plant-based
protein like beans or lentils to her
lunch salad or topping off her protein
oats with some sprinkles like hemp
hearts or flax but honestly the girl
clearly knows her stuff so if it works
for her it works for me all in all
chrissy was honestly a pleasure to both
watch and review
seeing her relaxed flexible and excited
approach to food was extremely
refreshing especially for an influencer
in the fitness space and on that note
that is all that i have for you guys
today thank you again to bright sellers
for sponsoring this video if you liked
it be sure to give it the thumbs up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen
bye